Autant les vieux face à la technologie ils sont tous un peu pareils
Autant les jeunes, il y a plein de types différents
Peut- être même que vous en êtes un
sur Snapchat
Celle qui n'a plus de nez
Soit c'est un filtre Snapchat
soit c'est le cadrage
soit c'est sa main devant son visage.
Bref, on verra jamais son visage en entier.
Quitte à cacher ton visage tout le temps, autant mettre ça, ça ira plus vite
L'espion.
Il snap tout le temps sans prévenir, en scred'
Tu fais un snap là ?
Non...
Mais tu préviens quand tu fais un snap, c'est tout. Tu fais pas ça en scred.
Non je fais pas de snap
*Tu préviens quand tu fais un snap (vient du téléphone)*
Tu l'as là celui-là ?
Tu l'as ou pas ?
L'horloge. Ça c'est le mec qui met l'heure sur tous ses snaps
Pour montrer qu'il se lève tôt
ou qu'il se couche très tard parce que c'est un thug
Alors désolé mais moi ça me fait penser à ça
Une fois j'me souviens je m'étais couché vers minuit dix
Bonjour comment j'étais fatigué après !
...fatigué après ! (d'après une imitation excellente bien évidemment)
Le chanteur. Voilà tous ces snaps sont en musique
Il rêve d'être chanteur
Je me demande ce qu'il en empêche
*Damso − Macarena * "Mais p't-être que sans moi le monde s'ra à toi. Et p't-être qu'avec lui"
*chantant mal*  le monde sera à vous et sera peut être mieux ainsi...
...remets la musique steuplaît
Ouais je crois que c'est mieux...
*Damso − Macarena*  "...le monde s'ra à vous et c'est p't-être mieux ainsi. Mes sentiments dansent la macarena"
NE GÂCHE PAS MES SNAPS !                                                            (Téléphone) NE GÂCHE PAS MES SNAPS!
Et voilà c'est loupé !
Sur Twitter.
Bien évidemment sur Twitter il y a le fan de football
🎵 Football, football ! 🎵
🎵 Ma photo, ma bio ! 🎵
🎵 Je parle que du football  🎵
🎵Football🎵
🎵 Je parle que du football football !  🎵
🎵 Et rien d'autre ! Et rien d'autre ! 🎵
FOOTBALL !
Le livetwitter.
C'est le mec qui va passer toute sa soirée à commenter des émissions télés
du genre Koh-Lanta, Top Chef, Danse avec les stars
mais sur Twitter. Pourquoi ?
Franchement Roger sur l'épreuve du poteau si déjà s'il tient plus d'une minute
🎵 Si t'as pas d'ami, va sur Twitter 🎵
Le type pas très régulier sur Twitter.
Ouais il est pas... Il bombarde pas trop quoi...
🎵 Si t'as pas d'amis va sur Twitter 🎵
Ah oui j'ai failli oublier, bien sûr y a les fans de
🎵Manga Manga 🎵
🎵Dragon Ball  One Piece 🎵
🎵Je parle que du manga manga 🎵
🎵Manga🎵
Sur Facebook, l'ajouteur compulsif.
Tu le rencontres au bout de 4 secondes il t'ajoute sur Facebook
Rapide !
Salut, moi c'est Etienne !
Et moi c'est Cyprien
Cool
Voilà et là t'appuies sur -Confirmer-
Mon pote !
On va plus se quitter maintenant
Nickel !
Le stalker
Il vous a ajouté en ami sur Facebook, mais il ne poste rien
Ne like rien, et n'a même pas de photo de profil
Pour moi c'est un espion
Je vois tout, je sais tout, je vois tout de votre vie privée !
Le mégalo. C'est le mec qui poste ce message :
Non, tu dégages, hop là.
Instagram. Le mec en chien, tu vois très bien de quoi je parle.
Pas besoin de te l'expliquer je pense.
Mais tu suis que des bonnes meufs !
Ah non pas du tout c'est du fitness
C'est pour t'expliquer comment être bien dans ton corps, comment se muscler
Ouais c'est pour mater des culs quoi.
Parce que moi je fais du yoga ça n'a rien à voir
- Comment elle s'appelle ?
- "Yoga ass"
L'instabouffe.
S'il prend pas en photo son plat, il est pas bien !
- Vous avez fait votre choix ?
- C'est quoi le plat du jour ?
Lasagnes végétariennes.
Non ça va pas, non...
- Ah, vous n'aimez pas.
- Si j'adore mais c'est pas beau
Y'a quoi qui like sur votre carte ?
Je vais vous laisser réfléchir.
Burrata ? Hashtag Burrata ?
#Burrata
Elle est de quelle couleur votre burrata exactement ?
Le hastagueur
Sa photo elle est bidon, par contre il a mis tous les hashtags possibles
Ouais c'est bien ça.
Attends j'en ai d'autres
C'est moi ça !
La meuf qu'a tout le temps son téléphone devant son visage et qui se prend en photo devant un miroir
On connaît son corps, mais on verra pas sa gueule
T'as trop changé, j'te reconnais même pas c'est fou !
C'est normal j'ai changé de coque !
Ça va très bien avec tes yeux, qu'on voit pas mais que si on les voyait ..
Merci !
Et enfin le dernier type de personne sur Internet
Celui que je préfère particulièrement, c'est...
C'est celui qui est abonné à ma chaîne Youtube !
T'en fais partie ?
T'as déjà cliqué sur le nouveau bouton YouTube ? Juste au milieu là, comme ça tu peux t'abonner t'as plus d'excuses !
Sous-titrage : voir dans la description #Jambon